hey guys Ryan right here I'm gonna be
checking out the exclusive extended look
trailer that just came out for guardians
of the galaxy a lot of people have been
saying I should check this one out every
time there's a trailer off regarding to
the galaxy I get my [ __ ] comments
blown up about how I gotta check out the
new trailer you know everyone seems
really psyched about this but I was
reading something I think Edgar Wright
said it where like some people have been
responding kind of mixed about this but
I from my understanding I thought like
everyone was pretty positive about this
I don't know I mean it looks [ __ ]
awesome already I mean Jesus like
awesome science fiction world brought to
life
you got colorful characters in there I
mean you got Chris Pratt as the lead
he's [ __ ] awesome Zoe Saldana sexiest
[ __ ] Vin Diesel as Groot
[ __ ] that Jewish guy in the ass not not
an insulting way I would penetrate him
out of mutual consent Bradley Cooper is
rocket racoon come on
Bautista wrestler as I don't know a lot
of guys are gonna hate me for not
knowing that yeah I want to see this
trailer
let's check this [ __ ] out
I mean like folks would wash stuff
families and we're facing a threat that
could destroy us all
whoa see we're gonna have to do it
together
partners
why would you wanna say the galaxy
why would you risk your life for this
because right now giving us a chance to
do something good
so [ __ ] cool seriously
we're the freakin guardians of the
galaxy with them
I have a plan you've got a plan I have
part of a plan what percentage of a plan
I don't know
12% well-versed totally that is the most
real authentic hysterical laugh because
that is not a plan oh yeah so what it's
better than 11% what the hell does that
have to do with anything
thank you fruits the only one of you who
has a clue
get your tickets now at Fandango I think
we saw a slight bit of michael roark I
think that's the actor's name the guy
who was on the first like three seasons
of The Walking Dead played Henry I
believe the killer each trailer just
solidifies how awesome this film is
going to be I mean what more can you
really say it's just gonna be a [ __ ]
awesome time this might be my favorite
movie of the year already
based off the trailers alone it looks
fun exciting action-packed cool story
awesome [ __ ] characters it looks like
what summer movies are made of for sure
more than just big-budget extravaganza
looks like it's actually gonna have a
story and characters to back up the cool
action I just wish we got a little bit
more Benicio Del Toro's character but
maybe he'll be you know an awesome
surprise something fresh well thanks
guys for letting me know about this
extended trailer being out I mean I love
anything I could see of guardians of the
galaxy if you guys are new to the
channel you can click right here to
subscribe that would be very much
appreciated
I would love it very much if you're a
girl going down on you what's up baby
don't know why I went there with it I
want to get some shout outs here
Joseph's wha he said what's up real
rejects he's talking wall2 rejects I
love your guys's channel the reviews are
hilarious and the trailer reactions are
awesome and if it's not too much of a
hassle can you guys give me a shout out
don't know why I'm talking like this
please and thank you love you guys oh
and you should check out the last of us
my favorite game ever sure I'll check
that out soon that is a very nice
compliment but you know you said if it's
not a hassle and it's kind of a hassle
to give you a shout out Joseph I mean I
gotta go out of my way to I gotta use my
vocal cords to say your [ __ ] name do
I really want to do that Joseph sauce do
i yes I will say yes to you Joseph's was
shut out it's some Hussein shut out
brother it's on I guess is username is
it Sam Hussein if that's their username
why would our geo who's saying you know
who we're all going
think of Saddam Khan
I think of Khan from Mortal Kombat that
guy is awesome
not the videogame character I'm talking
specifically about Mortal Kombat
annihilation okay it's um
forget the game Mortal Kombat
annihilation the movie is the real
definition of Kahn quote me on that
everyone I want to see you takes me
seriously but it's um you wanted to
shout out my brother uterus or shot
though brother that it was racist
David Santos he said love the channel I
would love a shout out well I love you
and I love your channel too don't know
what it consists stuff don't even know
if you have videos up there but know
this I genuinely sincerely full
heartedly love you that's honest truth
right there no lie no [ __ ] I don't
know if you have a channel but whatever
Santos is actually my mom's maiden name
we might be related who knows we'll
compare penis sizes and see if we are if
it's the same size we're a match we
don't have to do blood tests we don't
have to go to quest Diagnostics lab and
draw blood no we
I gotta compare our dick sizes I don't
know why I already won it's already
bigger than yours I can tell